favorite person you ever faced off  favorite person you enjoyed playing  against over and over again  like you wanted to prove a point  michael jordan  patrick ewing  elijah juan  alonzo  all the greats  because when i was dylan's age i was  also a medium level juvenile delinquent  so i was always on punishment a lot but  luckily i have a tv  right and every saturday karate movies  would come on and they're all the same  but basically at some point the student  must kill the master  to become the master so if i'm coming in  and you got this guy's patriot and who's  the master okay patrick you're here  comes shaq fu  you got you got you got barclay who's  posing me like i'm like i'm trying to  get all these guys because i want their  spot i want what they have so  you know i always tell people i live  with karate kids who are the life  everything that i went through has  prepared me for now